I'm really happy to be here for many
different reasons one of them being that
I just checked the weather forecast for
Toronto where I'm from and they're
expecting a major snowstorm today so I'm
really happy to be here so to provide a
little bit of more general background so
my broad research interests are in
system reliability and what I do care
about in particular is how do systems
fail in the field and the reason that
I'm interested in that as a research
error is that if you want to answer this
question with information that's out
there publicly available it's very
difficult so you could for example
follow the news and then you see stories
like the one of the men in Colorado
which you might have heard about a man
who was very frustrated with his
computer and he took it at night in a
dark back alley and he shot at eight
times and the computer failed so maybe
that was a bit sensationalist but if you
read The Guardian a Pulitzer
prize-winning newspaper had to headline
recently millions are driven to attack
their computers so basically it would
believe that millions of computers fail
just because they are killed but maybe
that's not what's really happening so
you could look at different source of
information so you could for example
look at vendors data sheets which
provide for each other or component all
kinds of specs including some
reliability specs the problem is that
the specs that vendors put out our specs
that they put out to convince customers
to buy a desktop so maybe it's not the
most objective source of information so
what I'm trying to do my work is work
with companies work with large-scale
production systems and get real field
data for those systems and in the past
so I've spent quite a bit of effort on
that I've gotten data from a bunch of
companies large companies like Google or
network appliances major storage vendor
got a few who prefer to remain anonymous
and then I've gotten a bunch of data
also from National Lab supercomputing
sides sign it for example which is
Canada's largest supercomputer just
because these guys have a lot of
hardware sitting around so they do see a
lot of failures and that of more willing
to share the data then
companies are so over the years I've
gotten a pretty broad collection of all
kinds of different failures things that
can go wrong when you're home things
like hardware replacement yes yes by the
way yes um have you also considered
talking locally here to the Internet
Archive yes that is actually a good idea
and I have not yeah still wrong friday
lunch they have my paints leaving
tomorrow at 7am but that's actually
that's actually a good point yeah you
feel worse yeah I mean the problems you
need to have places that have large
amount of data and that also very good
at collecting and keeping data about
failures and whatever else is happening
so that's the end they're willing to
share so that narrows down the field
quite a bit so different types of phase
that I have gotten data on things like
hard work placements a bunch of
different error modes in storage systems
generally server outages freeze mister
blue coats of job blogs why do jobs in
large-scale massively distributed
systems fail and one thing that across
all these different types of failures or
errors that have looked at that kind of
struck me is that I was talking to all
these people that people had provided
data the operators operators of those
systems i've talked to vendors who are
often surprised about how they are
components behave in the field i I
couldn't figure out I mean you have two
people who make those systems and you
have the people who run them and a lot
of the observation that I got were
really surprising and they were
surprising even to those people the
operators and the manufacturers and what
I've kind of tells you is that really in
the field reliability often looks very
different from what you can get out of
simple tests in the lab where you take
components you put them under some
accelerated life stress testing and see
how they behave if you do that so if you
artificially aged them basically oh
maybe they don't want to it's another I
didn't want to say that you said that
this being recorded
they need to check the system but it's
possible right if you yeah yeah so what
I'm going to focus about today is one of
very recent things that I've worked on
that is flash reliability it's actually
something that published just yesterday
at a fast that's actual brings me to
town so failures in solid-state drives
is what I'll focus on for this talk and
you might ask why flash the answer is
pretty clear if you think about it
normal data is living on flash a lot of
systems are now all flash actually the
market share keeps increasing so as more
day it doesn't even one flesh obviously
the reliability of all day that depends
on the reliability of the underlying
flash and then with flash in particular
as always this general fear because
flash is known to wear out so what
happens once you really use your flash
what happens to reliability once the
device we're out at the motivation for
flashing particular was also that for
flash it's a relatively new technology
that studied really really well in the
lab and pretty much all our knowledge
that we have comes from those lab
studies now flash has been used in the
field for long enough that there is
actually few data available so but
that's not at the point where you can
actually say interesting things about
what's happening the field unfortunate
now this only one other field study that
was published by people from Facebook
last year so our goals basically get a
much broader and people understanding of
how does flash fail in the field how
reliable or unreliable is flash so the
data are that we used so this work at I
was doing well of us on sabbatical I
spent four months of my sabbatical at
Google the data that we use was
collected across Google's fleet it's a
really nice data set so first of all
because it does span all of googles
frida to cover six years of data it
includes more than ten drive models what
is really nice from a analytical or
measurement point of view view and
analyze this data is that these drives
are actually custom drives so the chips
are commodity flash chips that everyone
can buy then Google develop their own
FTL on their own ECC
for all the models that I'll include in
this talk the ECC and the FDL is the
same across models and what it means is
basically if we compare different models
we know for sure that differences we see
are due to difference in the underlying
flash and not due to differences because
the ECC was different or the FDA was
different so it makes meaningful
comparisons possible so the chips come
from four different chip vendors they
include all the common types of flesh
mlcs lce mlc and there's a lot of data
on what this drive actually experienced
why they were in the field so there's
data on repair events replacement events
that ships bed blocks but also all kinds
of different types of errors and
information about the workload that is
driving experience so it's a very rich
data set Google is one of those
companies it's really good about
collecting data for all the systems and
keeping this data also they don't just
keep the last few months that their
admins can use it for troubleshooting or
whatever you can go back to say 2004 for
whenever they started data collection
they have it all they might have to go
to tape and get it online for you but
what is all there so for doing metal and
studies like this this is pretty perfect
okay so ah it's a lot of data and we'll
be short talk in comparison so I focus
on some of the the key results but I'm
happy to take any questions and other
things or you of course always welcome
to redo the fast paper if you want to
all know all the details so we started
with a very high level a question and
that is once those drives go in
production they are deployed in the
field what is the lifetime so how long
do they last before they get replaced
due to a suspected hardware failures so
what's the replacement rate the annual
replacement rate for each year what
percentage of drives per year do you
expect to get replaced and that's what
this graph here shows you for all the
models that we had significant amount of
data so what you observe is replacement
rays yearly replacement raids of say one
two maybe two and a half percent and you
might wonder is that a lot was that a
little so to provide some perspective
one thing that you could do is look at
hard disk drives let's in the meantime
been quite a bit of data published on
how to strive failing in
field you see very broad range ranging
from two percent up to twenty percent
Backblaze one of the companies and the
Bay Area made AC some data publicly
available that you might have seen so
the averages are probably in the range
of four to five percent so that's good
news so in terms of replacement rates
you see the flash it's actually lot
lower than hard disk drives and one of
the reasons that might have helped these
particular drives in this population is
that Google building a mechanism that
allows drives to tolerate a certain
number of chips failures so when it ship
fails it doesn't mean that the drive is
bad means this is more just ignore this
chip map it out and the drive will
continue to operate with reduced
capacity and some commodity drives do
that they do that by putting in spare
chips so it's something that happens and
commodity drives but not all of them so
about one percent of all drives see per
year in the field a chip failing so
these extra one percent would have had
to be replaced if they didn't have this
mechanism for tolerating chip players so
that was the high level view that yes
yes sure ABC and D represent chief
manufacturers I am you see is the same
they represent different models yeah I
understand and the different models are
different in the type of flash they use
some of them are from the same vendors
so ABCD are not all from different
vendors and we looked at the effect of
vendors and its and I've seen the same
for hottest rising the same for DM it's
not always one vendor being better than
the other is each of them has some bad
models and some good models and it's not
as easy as saying okay I'll only by a
vendor X and I'd be fine yeah so what I
wanted to figure out it so it's that's
the high level picture how long do these
things last before we have to take them
out and replace them but something else
what we also wanted to look at why these
drives are in the field how will do they
behave what kind of errors do the
experience and these drives because
they're custom drives have very detailed
error reporting so we're not stuck
the standard smart interfaces that
commodity drives halfway of North adoro
how to interpret it so they have a lot
of different types of errors and at a
high level you can group them into two
different categories so they're
transparent arrows these are errors that
the drive can hide internally mask them
so there will never be visible outside
of the drive and then a non-transparent
errors that may be the drive tries but
it's not able to mask them so it will
have to return back an error to the
application higher app so transparent
errors would be something like
correctable error so you have a bunch of
bit flipped but there's five internal
ECC and you can correct those flip bits
and you can deliver the data that's
being requested there's a read and write
retry arrows so these are situations
where a read or write leads to an error
but the drive retries internally and
eventually it succeeds so that doesn't
become visible to the application the
operation still succeeds then there's an
erase erase error means the block cannot
be erased the drive drive tries to erase
a block and it can dish means this rock
is probably bad and cannot be used
anymore but it's not critical to the
application so for non transparent
errors one tie bar uncorrectable arrows
so you have too many bits flipped VCC
cannot handle it cannot correct it so at
that point you cannot read the data that
the application is requesting you to
read there's a final right where which
means a Wright led to an errand even
after retrying many many times you can
still not write the data that the
application asks you to write the
metadata arrows which means the drive
cannot ex access drive internal metadata
and their timeout errors which means the
drive just fails to respond in a timely
manner and there's a time odd so a
question was out of all these different
types of errors how frequent are there
so what percentage of drives in their
lifetime sees at least one of any of
these types of errors and this is a
graph that shows you the results for one
particular drive model but it's somewhat
representative for most drives so what
you see first of all if you look at the
top bar that's maybe not so surprising
pretty much all drive nearly one hundred
percent see correctable errors so
there's a reason why this drive have ECC
otherwise that would have errors all
over the place what's maybe more
interesting
if you look at the second most common
type of error that effects depending on
which five model you look at between a
quarter to more than half of all drives
are uncorrectable errors so these are
situations where the implication is
trying to read data and the drive cannot
deliver it because there were so many
bits corrupted that it couldn't correct
the corruptions and it has no idea what
data is that you're asking it for what
was stored there the athletic movements
are after error correction so you try
everything you can with the is you see
that you've stored and you can still not
correct it so the correctable ones are
the ones that after is see they go away
so they are there but you don't care
really correctable error logs yes
exactly so these guys so they're the
custom drive so Google has basic control
and what errors are reported and they
collect data on all these different
types of errors so for each day its
aggregate data so for each day I know
how many for particular drives how many
errors of each of these types have been
observed yeah the United rice car and to
end data protection that it means that
it could also the bad so I don't know it
for sure I probably wouldn't be allowed
to tell you if I knew but I would
suspect that this being Google Google
tends to do things and to end from the
application down to the hardware so I
would have pretty sure that they rely on
higher levels say the say the file
system level to put in those check sams
if they are problems that either the
drive has miss or I'm them at the errors
that are not at the low flash chip level
right but that happen higher up in the
stack to protect against those mm-hmm is
the fpl open enough such that you could
have designed your eccie in a way that
those uncorruptible errors go away or
this is a problem right you you can
probably for any flash drive that you
design you could always make the ECC
insanely strong and have almost no
errors but then you have the problem
that it takes more time to completely to
see you need more space exactly
performance space they're all the other
overheads
so but whoever helped that you see this
was the perfect trader of failure rate
or I'm correctable Everett suppose in
general in one of the reasons that they
probably do that custom drives is
because then they can decide what is for
them the perfect trade-off between the
error rates that they see and they
overhead that this particular ACC
strength cost them that said though I
think it's very difficult and I talked
about that a little bit later on the
talk to decide because you have to
before you put these things into
production large-scale you have to
decide what's your eccie scheme right
and so you kind of stuck with doing that
test on for that trying to figure out
what is EC strength will I probably need
and that's not such an easy question as
I show you yeah so I can tell you is
that these are so the particular tips
that I'm looking at here what ships that
were put in production in 2006 the
lithography is ranges from around 40 to
50 nanometers who's relatively large
compared to chips now I can't tell you
any more details than that using linear
prediction okay they are not using
linear prediction corruption so what
basically used for they are decision
making and designing the FDL I don't
know because I was involved in the
process but I show you one standard way
that people use in lots of research
papers and other thing might not be the
best way yeah more questions yeah so
going back to these uncorrectable your
rights you might ask this this does look
high and if you compare that to hard
disk drives we've seen before the flash
drives have and observe replacement race
ever a big edge over hard disk drives
but if you look at sector error rates
and hard describes published papers
typically talk about three to four
percent of disk drive seeing in their
lifetime sector arrows that's much lower
and to some degree of course that is a
design choice again that disk
manufacturers figured that's what they
have to do to keep the customers happy
and it was actually yesterday at fast
there was a keynote by Eric Brewer from
google who was actually arguing that
Google would prefer if these
disk drives had higher error rate if
that means they can get them cheaper or
higher capacity or whatever so it
depends on what your particular needs
are they work around those and almost
funny piling more so by your own fault
detection yes I mean I guess if you now
look at a lot of data centers and how
they are run right the same is the case
for facebook or amazon there's so many
layers of redundancy at the higher
system level so if you always have three
copies of everything why does the Hat
just have to be like a hundred percent
reliable right you can deal with some
errors so that's true yeah so this error
rate these are always are pretty hot and
they're actually similar so this is not
necessarily Google specific thing those
are actually in similar rain assess what
the facebook paper has reported so it's
not something we please doing something
insanely different mm-hmm these have a
hundred percent ECC so every single all
the flash memory is protected or our
Sicilian effective so you mean are
different parts of the flash protected
with different strengths of ECC yeah the
day for one generation of models all the
flash chips all flash on one drive
always use the same as you see over
different generations the ECC change so
otherwise I'm talking about here the
first generation that have one strength
of ECC and there's a second and a third
generation of drives that have different
accs and I can tell you the strength of
the ECC and I can tell you anything
about the details of TL of the FDL
that's one of the things that could be
considered part of their IP and yeah
some of the trade-offs you have to make
if you want to get a sec where ever we
all of my business
engl yeah and it's it's another design
decision that you make when you design
your FTL oh right we're living is a
critical part and all I can say is that
laying versus for a usage by offering
when you arrest you right where you will
some parts faster than others if you
don't wear level perfectly and yeah the
FTL is proprietary and we can share it
what I would say is if this was just
because of you know stupid we're
leveling in the FTL these trials were
used for quite some time so if that were
the problem probably they would have
changed the FDL and just upgraded it
right updated it throughout the fleet so
it's it's not very likely that there
were some very obvious bugs or
inefficiencies that wouldn't happen
fixed it was such a long time period so
let's get you wondering the the other
arrow types that are relatively common
like read we try right we try or final
right arrows those are typically
considered symptoms of bad blocks or bad
ships and there's more detail about that
in the paper what I focus on in the talk
is uncollectible arrows correctable
errors because that seems to be the
dominating problem if you look at flash
reliability in the field so what we
didn't want to know after seeing those
error rates is what are the factors in
the field that affect flash reliability
so which one of the various things that
people talk about when they talk about
what effects flash is really a problem
in the field so the obvious contender
there is we're out as the number of
program erase cycles increases everybody
believes flash reliability goes down
there's a question of Technology and
I'll see versus slc lithography age and
workload and I look at all of these so
the question is when you look at
reliability what metrics should you use
and one metrics that I'm using is a very
widely used standard metric arbor arbor
basically means Rob bit error rate and
it means the number of errors number of
corrupted bits that you're seeing
divided by the number of bits they have
been read so for all these drives I had
information on the number of corrupted
and I knew how many reads happened I
remember these are production records
whatever how many weeds there were
depends on whatever the workloads were
that were running on these systems so I
didn't have control over that the second
metric is the probability of seeing an
uncorrectable error within a certain
time period and you might wonder if
you've looked at flat reliability why
I'm using the probability of seeing an
error rather than look at things like
like uber the uncorrect bit error rate
which is more common or traditional and
we see in the top why I'm not using that
so for now trust me that's a good idea
to look at probabilities so starting
with the fact or number one the effect
of wear out as a function of program
erase cycles so that's one thing we're
actually all the previous work that
looks at accelerated life testing in the
lab agrees as P cycles increase Arbor
grows exponentially as a function of P
cycles so I wanted to know is how does
this function look like for the drives
that we have data on that's what this
graph here shows you for those models
where we had data for large p cycle
range shows you for each model the arbor
as a function of the P cycles and if you
look at that graph to make two
observations one is that first of all
this big differences between the
different models I will talk about why
that might be the case the other
interesting observation is that really
there is increased clearly but it looks
much more linear than exponential and we
verify that with curve fitting it's
quite obvious just by looking at it so
that's clearly different from from what
people had expected another thing that's
very interesting because people always
have this angst what will happen if dr
crosses or exceeds the number of PE
cycles that the vendor specifies is the
maximum number that this drive can
tolerate will all my drive the same time
fall over cliff once they reach this
this limit so if you look at these
drives for almost all of them the p
cycle limit was three thousand as you
can see for those drives where we had
data passed it even pass this limit
there's no sudden jump or anything crazy
happening they the increase continues
but it continues at the at the
pace much slow so that is a good
question what would happen if they have
been used for longer and unfortunately i
don't know that because i'm stuck with
measurement data and there were not
enough drives that made it past this
this point but it was a lake do you use
mechanical strain stress yeah so what I
did try to do is I went back afterwards
after we did all the studies and I asked
the group at Google who did during the
procurement face all the tests on the
drives before they decided what to
purchase so for them some of these
drives I did get the data from the tests
and in those tests they did see an
exponential increase and they did
eventually also see very sharp increase
but that didn't happen until two or
three times the p-site limit so what
that tells you is that vendors are
probably very conservative about using
this this p cycle limit exactly yeah one
thing that you're missing and this
certificate remodels yours you don't
just care about number of pulmonary
cycles but also the time between program
recycles yes opportunity for relaxation
to happen yes and that yeah solutions to
some degree I can look at that but not
in a lot of detail the problem is that
the data I have is daily aggregates so I
cannot really say exactly how much time
there wasn't between I can look at
averages only yeah what's the 3,000 p
cycles consistent across all the vendors
because usually slc tends to have oh
wait yes I talked about it in a second
so that was the case only put the mlc
drives on top so the slc drives had one
hundred thousand cycles so there is a
messy used to be 10,000 cycles so there
are differences are closely it is it is
of course model-specific it's just for
these models I guess because they were
all put in the feet at the same time
they probably had similar although
although it's different vendors they had
similar technology and they had all the
3000 psi to limit so what's interesting
now is this was just for for our bruh
what happens if we look at our other
correctable arrows and you see actually
very slim a similar behavior so this
plots as a function of P cycles the
daily probability that a drive will see
an uncorrectable error so very similar
increase but it's linear and again no
sudden disasters that happen if you want
to reach the the piece I to limit the
joke was one right yeah the problem is
because only one thing a data point out
and that's where the data inlet I can't
say whether that was an outlier or
whether that's a trend because a lot of
other things so you have net was one of
the reasons actually looking at
probabilities they're more robust and if
you look at a trade especially mean
rates but it could also be a see spikes
also in other graphs for much lower
pieces could be that it just happened
that one data center for example had the
power outage and as a result all these
drives happen to have some issues with
their reliability and all kinds of other
factors that i cannot account for so
it's true for this one one data point
but yeah the jewelry consistency that's
what makes it very equational a little
bottom two ones are as it's easier so
they are very predictive but they also
very far from the end of their life in
terms of P cycles and that's actually
good next question what so what what is
the effect of slc versus and I'll see I
mean generally slc drives for those of
you who are not familiar with details of
flash technology are the much more
expensive drive and the reason is that
in a single flash cell you store any one
rather and my 2 bits and that
means that it's may be easier if it's to
get corrupted it also means that they
are more expensive because we get less
capacity out of out of a drive so what
is the difference going back to the
picture that we looked at and I've
already given it away before so the two
red lines are actually the slc drive so
for our it's very clear that these
drives if you better better arbor
weights and that's kind of what you
would expect so more interesting is if
you look at i'm correct blair us so if
you look at i'm correct barrows you see
that actually the worst model in the
whole debt aggression that one that
takes off pretty steeply at 500 p cycles
was actually in slc drive there are two
other slc models that I don't have
included in this slide because they
didn't cover a large enough range of P
cycles but out of those two Adam slc
models one was also consistently worse
than the M
she drives and one was better so
basically it seems when do you care what
uncorrectable errors the difference that
slc makes is not as predictable as when
you look at our words it's very clear
and again so all this drive he was the
same as you see it's not because there
was a different acc for different models
this is all due to the underlying
fleshly learning curve or something uh I
don't know I wouldn't 2000 when five six
years ago I wouldn't call that very
early and in the life cycle of flash
products and if anything I would
actually expect that based on the data I
have seen for later generations of flash
drives at Google that I didn't improve
in the paper because there wasn't a
large enough sample size there are
younger drives these things have gotten
worse although the ECCE has gotten
stronger the the error rates have
actually gotten worse shree crystal
because our photography exactly yeah
it's ready analysis done to say electron
microscope with it it's what people
idiom very high rates do that all the
time I'm sure I'm sure somebody has done
that for these what they say that few
data so i have no idea so nobody for
those super example for this model that
is so terrible the red one it takes off
I'm not sure whether anyone at Google
has ever looked into or whether whether
they talk to the manufacturer about what
is happening and it happens these kind
of things happen a lot also in the hard
disk word if you look at the data from
backblaze for example there are some
hard disks that stay always had like 12
percent failure rate and there's some
that in the second years ended up to ten
percent or twenty percent which is
terrible now that's some models that
turn out to be bad once they're in the
fields and if we could predict that
beforehand there would be great but it
shows you that's not that easy we
talking to a google so I was working
with the storage analytics group so
that's the group that hosted me but I
did a lot of this work in collaboration
with the group that was actually
developing the the FTL the sse and all
that
more hardware or ended people had four
platforms first of the talking tears
we're hopeful yes I'm sure he has seen a
draft of the paper because before you
publish anything this has to go up
pretty high and everybody has sign off
and I'm sure you sign up I haven't had a
chance to talk to him Roz Nia so this is
a error rates I did actually also
compare what happens if you look at
rates of repair or replacement and
compared slc and mlc and again slc drive
didn't look any better than the the mlc
drives which is kind of unexpected so
someone you point out the lithography in
that clearly has an effect so that's one
of the other things we looked at as
feature size the shrink density
increases you expected error rates are
probably going up so the drives in this
study do actually have different
lithography s so looking at average here
first if you focus on the red ones the
slc drives the one that is worse happens
to actually also be the one that has
small a little 34 vs 50 nanometers and
if you look at the mlc drives the blue
one which is clearly worse than the
others it's the only one that had 43
versus a 50 nanometer lithography so
clearly lithography as you would expect
that's impact arbor let's see what it
does to uncorrectable errors so if you
move to the uncorrect bits arrow slide
so actually those two models the red
triangles line and the blue line that
are within their class ones with the
smallest lithography are actually not
technically worse than the other drives
in their class at all so it seems that
for uncorrectable errors lithography
might have an effect but it doesn't seem
to be the dominating effect that gets
you on crack with arrows up or down
so one thing that we wanted about is
devices age for flash there's a lot of
focus on we're out due to pee cycles
growing over time but we wanted to know
is there maybe also wear out just
because a drive has been in production
for a long time and it has has been in
use even if it didn't have a very high
number p cycles so like that what is the
correlation between age measured just by
number of month that the drive was in
the field and arbor and this is the the
Spearman correlation coefficient that we
got for the different disk models for H
on the right side here and as you can
see they they are clearly very high
everything above point 1.2 you would
consider a clear correlation but the
problem of course is that there's a
clear correlation with P cycle as well
and if it wife is older it probably has
him more p cycles so we did actually a
lot of work separating out these factors
we did it in different ways one way
that's the easiest to present visually
is we took all the data points that we
had and we divided those data points in
two groups so I take all the drive days
that I have and then look at those five
days that were for older drives that
have been in feed for long at a time and
I make a separate group of data points
that are for younger drives that have
not been in the field for very long at
the time and then I plot their Arbor
separately against p cycles and what you
see if you do that is that the odor
drives are clearly worse than the
younger drives across the whole p cycle
spectrum so that basically tells you
that independently of p cycles just
being in the field for a longer time
increases your arbor so H has an effect
beyond just P cycle do swear yes also
possibly price worth it in my whole life
its design i bought the 70s actually
it's a good question because I should
have made it more clear so all the
drives that are included in this plot on
the right arrives from the same model so
they have the same FDL same ECC and
everything so just different data points
over there some drives that reach 3000 p
cycles in say one year and the others
that don't reach 3000 psi
it's under there three years old so you
can compare one year drive with fritos p
cycles with a three year old drive that
has two thousand p cycles and that's how
we do the comparison but we also did
statistical analysis and you can show
the effect of age independent of was one
of the things that I've meant meant that
I was talking about when somebody was
asking in a previous graph about the
spike in the end you sometimes see those
bikes and it's unfortunately it's pretty
much impossible to say exactly what has
what has happened but I can go back in
time look at the data but the only
information I have is what what the data
tells me and could be anything maybe
around that time in one data center
there was a failure of the cooling
system and rates went up or there was a
power didn't after that the hard way was
more flaky and it's really for for these
very high rates sometimes you know can
be one data center desk that kind of
bias is the sample so it's it's
difficult to say the best top model yeah
of course doesn't consist of that the
fuel the drives are on it I did try to
matter to the bathtub model as well
actually and so that's essentially what
the bathtub tells you you cannot do with
the bathtub right away because you will
see bathtub just because a stress get
older they're more p cycles so it is
aging because of program recycle where
are not just aging by itself I looked at
infant mortality and was very minimal
but that might just mean that no he was
not infant because the outlay also here
the automated to a thousand p cycles so
and last month it's true this to doesn't
tell you anything what about time i use
its yeah that's all you later and these
are the Younger Dryas yeah aah i didn't
looking for this specific case i look at
infant mortality in general and i saw
very very little the first few weeks
maybe and that might not make it
probably doesn't mean that there is no
info mentality it might just mean that
the testing that they do the burnin
testing before they put the device in
the field is good enough that you can
remove the infant mortality cases well i
would argue that first among as a lead
that is a very instant
they usually don't know there is an
ancient is probably higher than that
that is that's not very true right
because you might have some very bad
cases that in the beginning get the
curve up to yeah yeah you mentioned that
lithography didn't have in fact i'm i'm
correct Clara's so I I can't say that it
has no impact what I can only say is
that a dozen we do we a dominating
factor because those drives so each
class the MSC in slc class the ones with
the smallest lithography are not the
ones with the worst uncorrectable error
rates and this is possible that they
have strongly CC know all these drives
they all have the same as you see I know
that yes there's a nice thing about this
data that you don't get if you do a
study based on commodity drives you have
no idea for each other drives what the
FTL doesn't only what the SEC doesn't
turn aliso this he tells you read that
the differences must be due to the
underlying flash because everything else
is the same they're my different data
organization or where level anymore so
the we're living is the same as philly
it's like exactly the same code yes but
Colonel Chi UCC then of course to be
dispensed exactly so that that kind of
cost be different that's true yeah yeah
so I shouldn't show you see I'm a line
flash it's the flashed ship specific
yeah it's more correct so age does seem
to have an effect we use I just wear out
so one common concern that people also
have frequently is the effect of
workload and they have been lots of lab
studies that have demonstrated different
types of workload induced error most and
those include for example read and
program disturb errors were basically
reads or writes disturb neighboring
cells or incomplete erase operations
where block is not completely erased and
all these can affect your error rates so
the question is how dominant are these
error modes in the field is this what
affects your you're a berb so what we
did to answer the question is we looked
at in a given month is the arbor that we
seen that month correlated with a number
of reads number of rides or the number
of erase cycles that we see and when we
did that
we saw for these two models a pretty
clear correlation for each of these
reeds right Santa raises now that's
tricky so correlation doesn't mean
causation because all these free are
also correlated with P cycles so we did
more detailed analysis where we
separated those effects and what we see
is that for rights and erases the
correlation goes away if you control for
PE cycles for reads for at least two
models it still stays so the two models
where r e disturb in the field is an
issue and that's something the Facebook
paper for their workloads concluded we
disturb the few does not affect error
rates but that might be model specific
because we observe is for two models and
not for for the others so what about
uncorrectable errors we looked at the we
did exactly the same analysis front
corrected blares and turns out
uncorrectable errors and not correlated
at all with either reads or writes or
raises so the number of uncorrectable
error in the month is not created with
the number of reads writes erases the
probability and correctable errors is
not correlated with any of these so they
these are almost don't seem to affect
uncorrectable errors in a significant
way that's one thing that this means but
it means one other thing and I mentioned
before that I'm not looking at uber I'm
looking only at probabilities of
uncorrectable error so what fraction of
life days had and correct my errors and
the reason is if you do something like
raids where you say i will put errors as
so the number of uncorrectable arrows
and I'm have corrupted bits divided by
the number of bits that i read there's
an assumption that the number of
uncorrectable corrupted bits should be
normalized by the number of reads but if
there's no correlation between the two
it doesn't make sense to normalize
because if it does mean that if I'd
rather tease a lot of reeds and the
drive that sees very few reads the right
side sees a lot of reads will will look
much better an uber that's because we
haven't normalized by this huge number
of reads so if these two quantities are
independent it it does make sense it
makes sense in lab tests where for all
the tests you always run exactly the
same number of reads and then you
normalize everything by the same
constant but in our case over which we
distort the results
so now comes the question as always the
frustrating question for anyone doing
measurement studies there are other
factors that could potentially affect
fluff reliability that we have no data
on so for example I didn't have a chance
to look at environmental data like
temperature humidity maybe patterns in
the workload rather than just intensity
of workload so I can't a say anything
about those factors but I did try to get
an idea of whether there are factors
that have a big impact and the way I did
that is I looked at all the drives for
one model and those drives from this
model were deployed in different
clusters and what I saw is when I
plotted the population each cluster
separately against p cycles there's a
quite a bit of a difference in the arbor
rates for the same drive model deployed
in different clusters so what that tells
me is what the data I have all these
drives look pretty much the same so I
know they they are the same model I know
I'm controlling for P cycles so there
must be some factors that our classes
Pacific could be workload could be
environment conditions could be many
things that and what you do know but I
can say that there are some other
factors at play that we we can quantify
for a bit error rate for fashion way
most of them actually understand that
program recitals is not the only factor
in fact as I mentioned like the wreckage
plan between cycles very very important
yes and if you look we're not looking at
that you're hiding that effect yeah and
that's why I try to I try to look at a
few things so I try to look at got the
the problem when you look at few data
there's no way that you can ask people
to log individual read or write
operations or waste operations right
because the overhead would just be huge
so the only thing you can have these
aggregate counts so looked at some
workload specifics this big factors like
I try to look at the read/write ratio
and that was actually different for some
of the clusters and for some models it
seemed when there was a difference like
this
that could could maybe be a factor but
again I don't have fine wit enough data
that I could really throw down okay so
the next one is a more so stepping back
from specific factors and what impacts
flash reliability this is more a general
philosophical question that is so what's
the whole point of Arbor actually if you
think about why people care about our
they really use our bylaws it's a metric
for overall drive reliability right so
people use it in papers always in way
that's something similar to this paper
which is being sighted all over the
place where you have your raw bit error
rate and you say for a particular row
bit error rate and as a function of what
is you see I use what strength of ECC I
assume this rate of uncorrectable errors
and I think one of the reasons is that
so first of all Arbor is much easier to
measure in the lab and incorrect blares
because you see correctable errors all
the time so you can measure them
relatively easily and it allows you to
make predictions for different design
choices that you might make like
different easy see strength just based
on on one experiment right so what we
wanted to know is how where does Arbor
actually predict uncorrectable ears and
the motivation maybe on the previous
based on the previous slide is somewhat
clear there a lot of factors that affect
our burn and correctly rose very
differently so we started by looking at
the different disk models drive models
that we had and we looked at for each
drive model what was the median arbor
for this drive model and plotted that
against the fraction of the drive days
for this model that had uncorrectable
arrows and you look at this graph it
doesn't take a lot of time to figure out
the definitely no correlation whatsoever
and we verified that statistically so
for drive models with higher our there's
no higher frequency of uncorrectable
arrows but that's a pretty cause when of
you looking at drive models as a whole
right so we thought maybe what you
should do is you should take for one
drive model all the individual drives
and look for all them into the drive for
each
I've what was the arbor and was what was
the fraction of dr days with
uncorrectable arrows and that's a whole
population for one particular model so
again you see no correlation whatsoever
and you can show the statistically if
you don't trust your eyes we also looked
at even finer grained jetta we looked at
within individual dries what if you look
at individual drive days and you check
to drive days with higher our have
higher probability of seeing and
crackers again there was no correlation
whatsoever so what that basically means
is that our is really not a very good
predictor of those arrows that you care
most about the non transparent errors
and not very good predictors of feared
reliability what it also may be means is
that because how do you explain this
right why do these things look so
different so what it might mean is that
the mechanisms that cause a ver are just
different from the mechanism that cost
uncorrectable errors so maybe and I'm
not an electrical engineer or a device
expert but what could happen for example
is that you have retention errors were
slowly over time bits get corrupted and
that feeds into your Arbor and then
maybe in order to get uncorrectable
arrows these arrows maybe don't happen
because just randomly accidentally you
got unlucky and too many it's in your
eccie chun happen to be flip maybe it's
because there is something more serious
wrong with hardware maybe there's a chip
at its marginal and what parts of it are
failing and that's what really causes
your uncorrectable errors there just one
because you know when you look at know
ro ro bit errors you know like
particular sister caused by one
mechanism yes look at headquarters it
took you multi bits or a higher like
briefly went down some it's a different
maker right does he think my problem was
that I didn't have location information
so i wish i had known for each correct
row and crew era where exactly it
happened with Shipp which block and
where were in that block right but all I
have is these aggregate counts and I had
a very similar situation when I was
analyzing drm errors in the past Wes was
the same thing and I had
a similar conclusion than could be
detected change your measurement
infrastructure and edit basically login
sample logging of all the like addresses
that had errors and anybody should see
it the same addresses that are repeating
and might be something similar here you
also have no control over that sometimes
you find data a pendant here since today
it is very very possible and that that
could be that depending on how in which
order you exercise things and that's
something much that would be much harder
to log though because once you want to
log were closed and yeah it's yeah yeah
yeah so this mate might make you wonder
what is actually predictive of
uncorrectable error so Arbor is not very
predictive a bunch of other factors
don't seem to impact uncorrect where's
the way we think so one thing we thought
and it was going back to this hypothesis
that I have that maybe you know it's
it's something else as we leave a rock
the hardware smarter than something
that's wrong with the underlying
hardware so what we did look at is is
there may be a correlation between other
types of arrows or previous errors that
you have seen the drive and later and
correctable error so what we looked at
is we look at an average month for one
particular disk model so we looked at
all the drive month that we had and we
looked at for an average month so what
is the probability that in an average
month you see an uncorrectable error on
let's that tiny little bar on your right
there and then we looked at what is the
probability of seeing an uncorrectable
error within one month after seeing any
one of these previous types of arrows
and that is the the green bar the you
basicly says what's the probability of
seeing an uncorrectable error in the
month if at some point any point in the
past you've seen any one of those
previous types of errors and what you
seem that is kind of interesting pretty
much any type of previous error any one
of these different arrow types that the
drive log have some correlation with
later uncorrectable arrows so in some
way that's
positive news because it tells you
there'll be something that has some
predictive power about what are your
chances of seeing uncorrectable errors
one thing that I'm looking at right now
is can use machine learning techniques
for example and based on everything that
you know about a dr say the age the p
cycles previous arrows transparent or
non transparent and predict what the
chance of uncorrectable errors is and
we're playing around with this right now
so these are false positive again sports
negative rates for different models and
just a simple card model we've refined
that since then and depending on what
you want to use these predictions for
right so where is what false positive
rates is accepted to you what this graph
says is that for example if you want to
keep your false positives below half a
percent you can still catch around
thirty percent of all arrows which is
not all of them but catching a set of
them is better than then catching none
of them right now looking at so how good
can you make these predictions and if
you can predict think what you do with
that afterwards so this was some of the
findings now paper so we looked at a lot
of other things fee for example went
back and we looked at the test that
Google was doing in their lab before
putting the drives in the field and the
albert they were observing in those
tests how close were those actually to
the arbor observed in the field and they
were often quite a bit off we looked at
in detail how do bad blocks develop how
do bad develop for bad blocks one
thing that was pretty interesting is
that if you look at the number of bad
blocks on a drive as they develop in the
field you can see very small number 23
and once you pass a certain threshold
follow drives it was around five then
they developed massively so basically
once you have more than 34 handful you
very likely failure because that what is
that's what it means if you have massive
number of blocks fading is probably a
whole chip that's bad we also looked at
some things like all drives pretty much
come with factory bad blocks are bad
from the beginning and how many factory
bad blocks the drive has some degree is
actually also correlated with the later
behavior that this Drive sees in the
field so we look at more detail that
ships
we look at repair and replacement race
it's all stuff that you can fight in the
paper if you want to know more that for
now hi to summarize so some of the key
points basically were there's a
significant rate of non-transparent
errors uncorrectable error so flash
looks good for replacement grades but it
does not look very good for those
uncorrectable errors they are to some
degree predictable that is the good news
what it also means though is right now
all the fire systems everything storage
systems they have been developed with
hard disks in mind and if you move to
all flash and I haven't even taken it
into account these already the old flash
tips which lathered at a larger
lithography so as we move forward and
densities increase those errors are
probably not going down and more likely
to go up there's maybe something that as
a storage system of Isis and developer
you want to take a know how to make sure
that you protect against those those
problems and then it's something that I
found pretty much for all the different
types of failures I've looked at what
you find in the feed is really very
often different from expectations that
people have just based on previous
assumptions often adjuster anecdotes or
actual actual last lab tests so for
example that there was this linear
rather than exponential increase with P
cycles that arbor really doesn't
translate very well to what happens
about two uncorrectable errors at slc
when it comes to uncrackable arrows is
really not much better than mlc and yeah
there's quite a few other things that I
have in the paper that you are welcome
to read if you want with public since
yesterday I think so I'm how to take any
more questions if you have
did they provide you with any
information about the environment
temperature for the price um so this
data does exist and it would have been
really interested to look at I had only
four months that I spent there so I
didn't get it and the if you are
hundreds in temperature that's something
that the facebook paper actually did
look at so the facebook paper wasn't
some was a little bit more narrow
because they use commodity drive so they
didn't have all this detailed reporting
they knew uncorrect blares I didn't know
anything about Arbor or other types of
errors that drives are relatively young
but they have other factors that i
didn't have information about such as
temperature yeah and there was another
target liat fast yesterday they talked
about but also in context of hard disks
not but flash that actually looked at
three cool data centers and they found
that rather than temperature humidity
was actually a very much bigger
contributor to hard disk fit yes that's
interesting your initial slide and non
google yes yes most of the talk didn't
seem to mention the other stuff and so
for flesh for flesh data all the data i
have is google so the other data was for
all kinds of other things that i have
looked at in my life so I have looked at
lots of different types of of errors and
all the data comes from all kinds of
different places the flash data is from
google have been talking before going to
google I've worked with Google in the
past I had very good experiences I would
have been curious just you know to
brought my experiences work with other
companies and I wasn't disgusted with
some but it's really hard to find comedy
said first of all have a large number of
machines let's collect really good data
and that they're willing to publish
about it and in the end I was back at
Google hey so you mentioned the Milky
paper yes for meat oh yeah and actually
if you read like some of his work he
actually talks about why you know if you
look at kind of what we do that yeah
worst case yes but expect the painful
exponentially
great yeah well when you look at a
realistic case yes you know we're not
going to support our racing yes for some
work little dependence yeah you want you
don't expect this exponential so so this
work actually for some of these way I
don't explain yes many factors yeah i
mean what from what I remember about
this paper though is that that might
explain also the the differences from
from the field and in research papers I
think the assumption that he makes is
that there's a certain probability that
it's will trip and we just look at
depending on your eccie what is the
chance that more bits will be flipped
than what your eccie can support and
it's kind of a the assumption of things
happen randomly and I think what this
data says it's basically reward failures
don't happen because random events like
random bit flips just all happen at the
same time because that's what you can
protect against really easy by doing
this math it's when you have correlated
failures because there's some underlying
cause some problem you had when suddenly
you have many more things for
simultaneously then you were thinking
it's likely a failures were uncorrelated
any more questions yes i'm not i'm not
sure what i'm asking for how to destiny
but i think that different types of
servers would have different types of
read/write patterns a google machine
that's the library that has everything
archive yes could be doing read onlys
for hours at a time i'm going it update
occasion and it eventually so on these
drives all the drives from one
generation they have the same FTL the
same ECC's they were not optimized for
one particular application they are used
across all the different applications at
Google and those might look very
different so I like it that's how
there's one reason why I can get some of
these results why I can get some drives
that are very young and have a pretty
high p sub account already in some that
are pretty old until have a blow p cycle
count I guess part of what I'm wondering
was whether
within a company like Google whether
they isolate different servers to be
different functions or does every
machine do a broad mix of everything
that has to be done without trying to
segregate no different so there are some
classes that are reserved for particular
purposes but I didn't have information
about what was running in which cluster
I mean I did have information about the
worker in the sense that i had the
counts of number of read operations
number of write operations number of
arrays operations per day but that's all
the information information i had and
the most common news actually for across
all this workload was as a as a caching
layer not so much as as persistent
permanent storage so yeah yeah what
happened structure I audience so I have
some data and that's not that's still
not 3d this is things that were in
production put in production a few years
ago but it was basically this the second
the third generation of drives and
although the ECC was changed and get
stronger over time error rates
nevertheless get worse so that doesn't
look that looked good but but then I
mean people also do different things
internally in at the FTL right people
are talking about I don't using for
example raid across different flash
chips who knows what what we will come
up with to to counteract the decrease in
individual flash cell reliability
wanting to do with caches and you can do
a little scales you can sort of those
what I'm doing refresh and bring run
through industry image or whatever
changed it changed like the ECC after
six months yes and it's so this so one
of the things that I was thinking about
so given that we work on prediction it
looks like you can somewhat predict
maybe not simply on Arbor or number of
pieces alone that you've seen you can
take me other things to account you can
maybe predict how do you use that and
one thing would be that you do some form
of adaptive is you see yeah that makes
perfect
cool yeah i've got all over everything
so that's what Google does that spider
no Tony why not you see everything in
the cloud is open that clouds up all the
problems so d bad guys got good enough
that they were having you know cosmic
rays the fish sound anything like that
so cosmic rays are our one thing as I
look at the around reliability and I
didn't she try to figure out what the
custom Rays are an issue or not and they
are probably affecting error rates but
not so much uncorrectable error ways
because what I see so for DRM as well is
similar to what I'm seeing here there
was a very strong correlation between
errors so if you have yeah the high
number of errors on a dim or even like
on a particular address it keeps
repeating and if it was cosmic rays it's
not very likely that the class McQuaid's
would always hit the exact same spot on
the drm excuse me erase or at least say
that's too hard on it um it might be a
bad cells it might be like there was
also row and column correlations is it
exactly harshly broke exactly one of the
things that we detect a simulaid is what
if you at the operating system level
even if it is this how you treat ability
of errors what if you just at the
operating system there at that point
decided so the page the physical page
that uses that part of the drm dim the
OS world does decide not to use it
anymore and you lose where a 4k whatever
your page size is in memory but that's
pretty small compared to your overall
memory and that fixes a lot of the
issues that you will have further down
the road actually and we did a detailed
simulation study of that personally I'll
let you to analyze your infant mortality
stories and correlated with the physics
you can make much better predictions
someone like process versus the law
taking averages than the asuma-sensei
calcium sent to live with you that's
very different yes and anything else new
beverage is your sexually averaged out
for others physics so that's my monster
that is true and I mean I can do lots of
stars whatever doesn't why ever desire
our problem one of the reasons averages
our problem is that they are clearly
correlations so one dry some drives are
bad and they just get really bad so I
haven't made this a big point but if you
look at the labels on normal grass
advice for example median arbor really
and not mean arbor because if you take
means you don't see any Trent it's so
blurred by those individual points that
outliers in the spectrum to the degree
that they do Wharf everything else
president advocated some point harmonic
need for inspiration there's a very good
athlete that other needs to the stand of
me yes it's coral in two thousand in
some sense but that was making sense
yeah okay thank you thank you
you